good yeah
Oh
this is a five axis state-of-the-art
water jet the water comes out at 2,000
miles an hour and cut anything and
believe me and get anything
yeah fine made solid sodium hydroxide
which in principle to react with the
butter though we may need to add little
water it's melted the butter
unfortunately you wouldn't want to eat
the batter after this whereas with the
laser or some of the others it would be
fine with this you've turned your batter
into soap so I think we're just about
there I mean it so when we've washed
everything away you can see that we are
we have separated the butter into two
pieces
but it's so dead that nobody would
really want it at all
so I regard this as a complete failure
as an experiment that it shows it's
possible
you